foreign
folks welcome to rational science the
only site on the internet that does
physics rationally everybody else does
but mathematics that's what it's called
mathematics they move Concepts around
they move uh the mass they carry the
mass they transfer the energy and they
uh shake the field
you know and they think they're moving
objects it's all math that's all it is
they have no explanation of how this
universe works okay we're going to be
doing a little bit of uh space time
today a little review of special
relativity and uh while we're at we're
also going to be doing the subject
matter of today which is gravity okay
and then uh we're gonna have some
questions at the end as well uh that
we're going to answer from people who
ask them during the week actually from
two weeks ago we didn't have time last
time so we're going to cover that and uh
we're gonna start out with our
Extinction segment and
hello
and then uh we're gonna uh look at some
of the headlines that are happening
today you know and how they affect how
they're related to Extinction again we
don't do politics here really we're not
we try not to I mean sometimes we might
uh not uh really uh intentionally what
we want to do is relate uh the uh
headlines and some of the news that's
out there to Extinction how it relates
to Extinction and again what we're
saying is that Extinction is an issue of
um
ecological pyramid overturn okay the
ecological pyramid is going to overturn
on us and there is absolutely nothing we
can do about it okay we we might be able
to postpone it a little or shorten it a
little you know the postpone it or make
it come sooner but other than that we
cannot avoid it all together
okay so let's get going with our
Extinction segment here we have uh one
bit of news says China renews Embrace of
maduro's Venezuela as the U.S looks on
okay uh and so what is it Venezuelan
China are reestablishing connections
after years of cooling ties with
government contacts resuming and Joint
projects uh floated in what amounts to a
challenge to Washington
now what I put up there is 2016 a map
that shows all the bases that the United
States has around China that was in
2016. and a lot of these are renewed
others you know are new ones that have
uh been put in place since then
and uh it says that at the bottom two
day more than 400 and that's 2016 right
more than 400 American military bases
encircle China with missiles bombers
warships and nuclear weapons okay but on
the other hand imagine now that China
were to do something similar it starts
you know uh having relations again with
Venezuela uh that read uh country there
at the north of South America uh it
already has relations with Cuba they
share a common ideology communism right
a political ideology and then you have
Nicaragua which more or less is in the
same boat and they have good relations
with these three countries they could
start new relations with other countries
that might depend more and more on China
for example Brazil the big country there
um it's number one uh trading partner is
now no longer the United States but
China and so just imagine that and I've
been to Argentina and let me tell you
lots of Chinese over there lately and so
imagine that uh goes beyond just the
commercial aspect and they start putting
their aircraft carrier years as you see
there around the Caribbean maybe even in
Mexico you know remember Mexico might
has a little bit of a gripe against the
United States you might want to recover
the territory from Texas to California
uh and uh the fact that uh
you know that was taken away by uh
President Polk in the 1840s and uh you
might think that maybe the Mexicans have
already taken there's more Mexicans
they're the standard Americans right all
that uh Southern uh part of the United
States I know because I live there and
um so just imagine that Mexico were to
have relations with China to a point not
just commercial relations but military
you know they decide to do joint
exercises as they're called around the
United States what do you think the
United States would do uh would the
United States be happy with that
uh so that's more or less the situation
over there in China just think about
that they're all mafias
you know I look at them it's all mafias
so one Mafia say hey you're in my my
backyard I don't like you over here you
know with all your weapons and you know
your machine guns and bombs and Hand
Grenades and the others say uh well you
know we're pretty we're taking democracy
we're protecting all these countries you
know okay you know so there's always
excuses to surround the country and just
wonder a little bit what would happen if
it's in reverse that imagine what
happened in uh what was it 61 with uh
Khrushchev
um sending uh more than just standard
missiles but icbms uh into Cuba you know
the United States didn't like that at
all and so that's more or less the
situation all these mafias you know they
try to see what they can get away with
you know so
that's where the world is
okay uh here's uh another piece of
um news and it's a little contradictory
because on the one hand same day by the
way may the 3rd okay and in one headline
says U.S Envoy to China says next steps
to improve relations are up to Beijing
and uh the envoy you know he says we
need better channels between the two
governments and deeper channels and we
are ready to talk Bern said speaking to
the la la la okay and we've never been
shy of talking we hope the Chinese will
meet us halfway we don't want a conflict
with China we don't want to return to
the cold war with China and we need
greater stability in this relationship
same day the news comes out says U.S
senators lost some renewed pushed to
Thor China
talk about you know uh oxymorons there
you know double talk yeah no one hand
they want to improve ties and the other
uh Congress saying uh we're gonna we're
gonna create problems for China as many
as we can
yeah there there is a war going on
already there is a cold war so to speak
going on and the question is whether
that's going to lead to a hot War okay
in other matters here we have India you
know apparently as surpassed China as
the most populous nation not because
they counted everybody but because they
project the uh rates the growth rates
and so on you know and uh it says
China's population is likely to begin
shrinking next year so China's coming
down but India is still going up but it
says India's fertility rate has also
Fallen substantially in recent decades
from 5.7 births uh per woman in 1950 to
two births per women today and here you
can see the uh the chart okay you can
see what's happening to India's
population the last UH 60 70 years maybe
okay it's come down and so both
countries not only in China but the
United but uh India their rates are
coming down okay but it says the
following it says um the U.N expects the
population to Peak around 2064 and then
declined gradually that's for India
right India having more people in China
is no longer significant in a concerning
way uh what do you mean by that well it
says Rising incomes and improved access
to health and education have helped
Indian women have fewer children than
before effectively flattening the growth
curve okay so they think that's positive
okay because uh they're not producing
children instead they're producing
something for the economy and their
incomes are rising their health and
education are becoming you know more
modern
then there's migration and listen to
this as some 200 million Indians have
migrated within the country between
states and districts and their numbers
are bound to grow most are workers who
leave Villages for cities to find work
yeah it's known as urbanization it's
happening throughout the planet
okay everybody on the planet is every
country is having this urbanization
movement pretty much and our cities will
grow as migration increases because of
lack of jobs and low wages in The
Villages
okay so what's happening uh
what's the cause of women not having
children not having why the birth rate
is dropping every country on the planet
uh it's it's got to do with urbanization
that is the underlying cause and yeah
when you move to the city you've got
different education you've got uh
different especially economic situation
right uh maybe you can't afford 10
children anymore like you did in the
country okay so these are the situation
but I think the bottom uh line is that
uh
As you move to the city you know you
stop having children there's no room for
children in the cities
and same thing is happening in the U.S
here's the U.S okay more U.S women are
avoiding unwanted and missed time
pregnancies births and pregnancies in
the U.S have been on a long-term decline
in new data analysis provides one reason
it's becoming less common for women to
get pregnant when they don't want to be
okay it sounds like they used to do uh
you know forced sex in the past is that
what they mean by this and they don't
want to be now okay what happened before
the data indicates that far fewer
individuals were becoming pregnant in
2015 then in 2009 in that abortion
incidents went down because individuals
do not get pregnant not because their
pregnancies continued to a birth instead
of an abortion there's also data showing
that young people are having less sex
perhaps because they are socializing
online more and engaging in pure risky
behaviors overall and yeah then there's
the issue of Economics especially if the
kid stays at home you know there's very
little chance of them forming a family
and they don't care about that anymore
they probably have some casual sex out
there then come back home and they're
not going to have kids inside their own
home their parents home you know
fertility rate has been increasing among
the oldest child bearing women so women
are having babies later on in life 35 to
44. they run into fertility troubles at
older ages so I think not only are they
having them later but the kids are not
coming out right
uh I think that's happening as well okay
but a lot of them need help of all
Source uh
maybe there's more cesareans you know
and this is the trend look at the trend
scary yeah look
uh this is uh since the 1800s
uh do you think the raid has come down
and where is it headed well further down
certainly not going up United States is
making up for all that with immigration
so the United States is allowing All
European countries as well by the way
Western European country especially
they're allowing immigration and because
you know immigration is kind of
replacing the lack of kids the fertility
in other words right that's that that's
not happy and so keep that in mind but
fertility is dropping in countries like
Nigeria which used to have much higher
rate of
children production you know now all
those people are moving to the cities
again to the big cities and they're not
having children and what few children
they do have are coming to Europe in the
United States you know from India from
China from different places from all of
Africa
okay we discussed this last time with my
son it's got to do with hey eyes Okay
and one fellow who worked in the
industry now quit so he can uh speak his
mind
and they say artificial intelligence
Pioneer leaves Google and warns about
Technology's future
and I've got a problem with what he says
because on the one hand he says that
there's a problem with Bad actors using
it for bad things okay that's that's one
concern about you know the warning for
the future and then on the other said
the idea that this stuff could actually
get smarter than people a few people
believed that you know and now he does
believe it and it's going to happen
sooner than later well we got a problem
uh what is the issue with AIS is it that
someone might use the AI for bad things
or is it that the AI is going to get
smarter than people and will not need a
bad actor to direct them to you know
rule over him so we have two situations
here and uh you know these people do not
you know really reconcile these two
different versions are we concerned
about Bad actors using AIS or are we
worried about AIS taking over the world
because they get smarter than people
and meanwhile uh as well says that uh
what the AIS are being used for is to
replace people we went in healthcare
climate education engineering and uh
yeah if anything they're going to be
pushing people out of work that's uh you
know again maybe the last stage of
efficiency in a in an economy where they
bring these AIS they do a lot of work
that humans don't do either as well
or or whatever you know the AI does it
more efficiently for sure you don't have
to pay them a salary so in that sense
it's more efficient it's more cost
effective so uh you know it might happen
that AIS replace humans in many aspects
in many parts of the economy when not if
but when that happens all we're just
doing is creating more unemployment if
anything where are we going to put
people to work you know are they going
to just stay at home and receive a
paycheck from the government is that the
way it works in a uh future Society
so keep all this in mind AIS if anything
make everything more efficient and
that's not good the more efficient we
become the less work there is
especially if there is no one to buy the
product because they're on welfare or
whatever or unemployment and so they
don't have as much disposable income to
go out there and buy you know
especially expensive goods and because
of that you know they don't sell this
many the big companies that produce
these Goods compete against each other
they kind of uh merge or go out of
business or whatever and that's more
unemployment and so on and so yeah AI is
not good news for the economy at all if
anything but for them taking over humans
uh that's as far as I'm concerned that's
Hollywood stuff it's got nothing to do
with reality it'll never happen
and uh here's a fellow says uh regarding
some of my extinction theories and he
says he doesn't accept that you know
it's going to happen through uh food or
through ecological pyramid overturn says
I don't think reconstructing past
extinctions which is what I suggested
the other day I said uh we should do 101
Extinction 101 before we do extinction
102. extinction 101 mass extinction or
just Extinction you you can do
background or back or mass whichever one
you want but you have to explain mass
extinction you got to say look this is
how Extinction occurred in the past with
the animals that and plants that have
disappeared please explain that first
then you show that you know something
about extension and everybody wants to
brush that off this fellow also he says
well I'm not going to do that because
it's not relevant to humans okay and so
he says what's going to happen was
Modern ecological conditions rearrange
the natural order talks about natural
order and talk about ecology so the guy
is looking at the environment not only
you know your surroundings but also you
the food the diseases these kinds of
things that's what he's got going
through his mind right A lot of people
think like him biosphere collapse that's
what he's got in his mind he's got
addictions you know shooting up Etc
Hedonism uh profit modem you know all
these big corporations just taking
advantage of us poor little people you
know they sell us all this garbage that
we don't need and that's bad for uh the
environment essentially right because we
have all this nonsense that we don't
need
infertility okay uh and then we have
poison air poison water poison
everything everything's poison they sell
us all this poison that we have to eat
because there's nothing else to eat in
the cities especially right and so a lot
of people think like him they think
there's this great conspiracy up there
uh the New World Order folk the
Illuminati and what they do is you know
they have all these things up there that
they're shoving down our throats and
it's changing the environment and that's
what's going to kill us well the problem
here is that you know when he says the
ecological Collapse game or whatever
you gotta you can't just say the ecology
collapses you got to show me a mechanism
you haven't explained the mechanism how
all this kills us
okay how does this produce the
extinction of humans
none of this this is just a shopping
list of of gripes uh I don't like the
government I don't like the modern
society because look at all the stuff
that we got out there we have
prostitutes in one place we have uh all
these drugs in the other place it's a
mess out there yeah none of that
explains Extinction
Okay so
please explain the mechanism of
Extinction don't just say ecological
collapse because that doesn't tell us
anything okay you gotta have a mechanism
and again that's why he avoids
um
past extinctions because he cannot
explain them he would not be able to
explain how the dinosaur disappeared or
uh you know the Permian animals Triassic
and so on he would not be able to
explain that and so he wants to skip
that I said no let's go to humans
because we're unlike all the other
animals we're not animals that's more or
less their way of thinking yes we are
animals we belong to the world called
mammals but people think that because we
have a higher level of intelligence in
all other species out there that somehow
God designated us The Keeper of the
garden you know where the Gardeners of
Eden
uh main gardeners you know the guy in
church we're not we're just another
little animal in the Kingdom okay and
Eden and people don't understand that
they say no no we rule the planet yeah
so did the Triceratops I'm sorry the
Terry axes in their day they they rule
the planet and they're gone
didn't help but many of the fact that
they were the top predator
Apex brother right okay another foul
says the following he says uh there are
too many people for food shortages to
cause Extinction Africa is a great
example feed Africa and the population
explodes until the infrastructure can't
take it okay then a massive famine okay
then a few years later the population
exploding again because the food is
being shipped in again
so they stopped shipping food in there
why because of money or what's the issue
if nothing else those who are willing to
eat people will have a readily available
food supply until population matches
carrying capacity of the land being
inhabited long on uh Sunland green and
let me for those of you who are not
familiar uh sunlight green it was a
movie that they had uh where um uh they
used people uh you know at the factory
they they put the people in inside there
inside a machine and that's where the
food came out of you know
the feed that they sold the people who
were living okay so
um and it says there and uh this is in
the Wikipedia just the first sentence
right it says by 2022 which is one year
ago right the cumulative effect that
this was a 70s movie by the way the
cumulative effects of overpopulation and
pollution have caused severe worldwide
shortages of food water and housing
so I just want to make sure that we
understand that that is not the theory
that we propose at all this is not a
question of shortages which is what this
fella thinks that it's a question of uh
you know uh being close to the carrying
capacity when you exceed it
right uh density dependent birth rates
right kind of thing uh there's gonna be
deaths and what happens is that brings
the population back down now it's back
to carrying capacity we're okay we're a
little too low we've started producing
children again that's what they have in
the back of their mind that there's this
seesaw going up and down
that's not the case not the case at all
that's not our Theory by the way what
we're saying is the global economy is
going to collapse it will collapse
there's no doubt about it it will
collapse because we cannot grow forever
economically okay we cannot grow forever
partly because population doesn't grow
forever and our global economy human
economy is based on the fact that or on
the expectation that in the future
there's going to be more people
you know more consumers and we're going
to have more demand and so companies say
okay we're going to expand because
there's going to be more demand if
population starts coming down or levels
off or whatever then these corporations
are going to have a problem because they
will not be able to through quality uh
replace quantity okay which is
essentially you know uh what demand is
you need to sell more and more goods and
services and what's going to happen is
if population comes down and people
maybe stay at home they don't need as
many services because they're just going
to stay with Mom and Dad or maybe they
get married and don't have kids they
have a place to stay you know they don't
need to keep buying and buying and
buying forever and especially if they
don't have kids you know there is no new
uh consumer base if that doesn't happen
the economy will definitely collapse so
what you got to look at is the
projections think of it this first in
the long terms that that helps you
reason it out are are humans going to
live a million years a million more
years
and the question is is population going
to increase in the next million years
uh how is it going to increase
exponentially arithmetically how is it
going to increase for the next million
years okay that's the first question you
have to answer or at least a factor that
you should keep in mind
so if you think that population is just
going to kind of stop
growing you know we're going to read
some kind of plateau and it's just going
to go up and down you know more or less
in a constant population overall uh well
you have to justify that because that's
not happening what's happening is the
population of the world is becoming
older of the world population of the
world of the entire planet is a human
population right is becoming older okay
that's one of the reasons we're having
fewer kids uh uh the other one being you
know we're moving to the cities
urbanization and if we have fewer kids
what you have is the overturning of the
population pyramid of humans globally in
general some countries will have a
little more uh younger people and he'll
have more kids but you know especially
the advanced Nations that they're not
going to have kids you know because
people are already settled they're you
know they're stabilized and the only way
they're going to get people is through
immigration and so the question is at
some point population is going to start
grow stop growing
especially as it used in the 19th
century where you know went
exponentially upwards that's going to
stop and it's already stopped in fact
and now it's leveling off and what's
going to happen is you got to double
whammy on the one hand you don't have
consumers and on the other you're
getting uh unemployment because you
don't have consumers uh companies close
because they can't sell their products
ever more right and at some point there
is a crisis and you have a collapse of
the global economy you can't just create
money out of nowhere and say oh we're
just going to give it to you and you
stay at home you know there because the
AI took over your job or whatever okay
so so the issue here is that if you're
going to say that humans are going to
live another million years but you got a
lot to justify
and if you say well a millionaires I
don't know what's going to happen in a
million years I don't care because I'm
going to die before that okay that's
that's true but then you got to have an
idea of whether it's gonna we're gonna
live another Thousand Years another 100
years another 10 years I mean if I get
down to 10 years will will you react and
say well no we're not going to die in 10
years we'll explain why why not
I mean you know maybe the global economy
collapses before the next 10 years and
then what what do we say you know so if
you say no please justify it okay that's
the way it works
okay let's move on to our uh I'm gonna
do a little review of special relativity
which we did last time yeah we've been
doing it for the last couple weeks yeah
we talked about the fact that um we have
the length contraction
and uh Mass increase and time dilation
and all that good stuff from special
relativity is any of that
stuff from special relativity it does is
that uh does that have anything to do
with science does that have anything at
all to do with physics
let's find out yeah here's uh
I'll start with my Universal movie okay
and the universal movie again is uh a
tool that I use I recommend it to
everybody and what it is is snapshots
you know you you had these Motion
Pictures especially you know when you
had in the 1920s and so on uh one frame
at a time you know went through the lens
and so if you just looked at one frame
well there's nothing moving inside the
frame if you want to see something
moving you know Motion Picture well you
had to have the the whole reel go
through the lens right so that it's
shown on the screen and so the question
is when you look at a single
uh frame of the film nothing is moving
in there that's more or less what we're
talking about when we say the universal
movie we're going to treat it as a movie
you can call it a three-dimensional
movie you can say God is it's God's
movie okay so God has filmed the movie
now he's got the film there a
three-dimensional film and so he's got
all this you look at any given frame and
everything is just static nothing is
moving you just took pictures you know
of what was happening in the universe
and what you see in one frame is just
all the atoms just in one location
you'll see all the planets in one
location you'll see that every Star and
galaxy everything is a given location
okay nothing's moving in that frame and
in order to see something moving you
have to go to at least two frames okay
so we have the universal movie single
frame nothing is moving and within that
you have only static Concepts you have
all the objects you have location you
have distance sense existence that's all
in a single frame you don't need motion
for any of those Concepts on the other
hand if you want to have you know motion
you want to have time well you got to go
at least to two frames in other words
you have to have the film Rolling Along
okay and that's more or less the notion
behind the universal movie and here you
see it okay here's the frames of the
film you have the uh static Concepts at
the top and the dynamic ones at the
bottom you can see the ones on the top
the yellow uh
region there it only points to a single
frame the beige one at the bottom points
to at least two frames and you can put
more if you want but at least two frames
is the minimum to create all these
Dynamic Concepts such as motion and time
and energy and so on okay why is length
and mass which is what we've been
covering why are those static Concepts
well we look at the definitions and
here's the definitions of physics okay
what is length continuous matter between
two surfaces
what is mass number of atoms okay
quantity of uh material matter that's
what mass is
and I just want to point out that not
only time is a dynamic concept which is
down there at the bottom right okay
which is time dilation uh so you can't
put it in there with length and mass but
you've got inertia and I just want you
to keep in mind inertia which is
resistance to motion okay in other words
a force comes against you and you push
in the opposite direction to that Force
that's called inertia it's a resistance
to change right and so inertia is a
dynamic concept A Nurse is not a synonym
of mass because mass is quantity of
matter okay so keep that in mind okay we
have a contradiction because they Define
mass as inertia and now they are two
different things if you're going to talk
about inertia inertia you can say almost
is the opposite of weight okay because
you have something weighing down or
sideways right and or pushing in a given
direction right and something that
opposed is it which is could be the
atoms that make up the thing that you're
weighing right or could be something
that is preventing that thing from
moving like you know you can put a box
on a table
and the inertia of that is zero really
because it's not moving at all okay
unless a force acts upon it right so
um
just keep that in mind uh Mass did it
lose its mass is mass zero because
inertia is zero
okay keep that in mind okay so here we
have a good old Stevie Hawking okay that
a few years ago and he wrote in his
Brief History of Time you'll find this
in the glossary okay Mass the quantity
of matter in a body it's inertia or
resistance to acceleration
well quantity of matter you know like if
you have 10 marbles in a bag there's
only 10 marbles in there that's quantity
of matter if you look at every marble is
you know a piece of matter as a unit of
matter so you got 10 marbles in there do
we need to know do we need to measure do
we need to count them no we don't Mother
Nature knows there's only 10 in that bag
before you count them before you measure
before you do anything there's already
10 in that bag you can later on count
them and say oh I counted them found out
that there's ten mother and each already
knew that God already knew that the
devil already knew that you know these
guys up there whom we pray to every day
they already knew
how many marbles are it's a fact it's a
question of existence there's there
exists 10 marbles in there whether you
count them or not okay this is not a
schroding gear cat kind of thing where
the cat is dead and alive at the same
time no God knows whether the cat is
dead or alive before you look
okay so uh just keep that in mind uh one
thing is existence and what is and the
other one is measurement what you
but you perceive what you measured or
what you understood maybe you're drunk
and you don't even know what you're
looking at so it doesn't matter what you
uh concluded what matters is what is
you know independent of your conclusion
and so here we have mass quantity of
manner and contradiction because uh
quantity of matter does not match
inertia which is resistance to
acceleration okay weight the force
exerted on a body by gravitational field
it is proportional to but not the same
it's its mass right of course uh because
um weight is inertia or you could say
it's the opposite of inertia weight is
what goes in the down in in nurses what
tries to prevent weight from going down
so it's kind of like an antonym of uh
weight that's what inertia is okay so
yeah if you define if you try to cover
all the bases like uh Hawking did there
and here you have a PhD many years of in
the industry theoretical physicist
physicists of mathematician right uh
yeah you don't Define terms uh precisely
why because you can get away with murder
if you define that word in two different
ways and you say look it's a quantity of
matters also inertia well which is it I
mean those two are not sent a quantity
of matter is not inertia okay okay
um
here we have um uh situation so it says
the following says uh well this was this
was from quora okay and I like what this
person said so I thought I'd put this up
there many people think inertia is Mass
others think it is momentum depends on
the object's mass and speed well others
think it is a force this guy says he's a
physicist okay it is not a quantity
even the vague idea is not well defined
in physics absolutely they don't Define
these terms because if they did they
would be in sorry shape it is best not
to it is best to not add to the
confusion don't use the word
there is absolutely no need for it there
is no bit of physics which requires the
use of inertia in most cases a better
word like mass does the job
okay and yeah there you have mass has
one trillion hydrogen atoms that's what
that box has
and it's a nurse I guess it's zero
because it's not moving anywhere
okay so what is its inertia
so uh yeah you can't say mass is inertia
absolutely not because inertia is really
related to motion whereas mass is not
mass is quantity of matter and if you
want to Define it otherwise then you
can't Define this quantity of matter and
we have a contradiction what do we what
are we going to call quantity of matter
then
you know when we say that we take the
grand kilo from uh
France you know the one that used to be
the standard for uh Mass
and we take it to the Moon it weighs
less
and people say well it's weight changed
but not its mass
and so what are we referring to when we
say that its mass did not change
well we're saying it's quantity of
matter did not change
what changes its attraction uh to the
center of the object the celestial
object that's what changed but the mass
did not change what do they mean by that
quantity of matter so then don't say
what's its inertia
inertia is weight in a different uh it's
a different way of rephrasing weight
that's all it is it's the opposite of
which so to speak like an antonym
okay so what are the conclusions that we
have from uh from uh
special relativity yeah from the last
couple weeks a prediction is not a
theory okay and we had that with our
science critic and we finished with him
because uh there's nothing more to
address I think we addressed every issue
that he raised okay so we're not going
to have this fall uh on here at least
not for now a prediction is just a
description you know if you say that
something's going to happen tomorrow so
far you haven't told us why you haven't
given us an explanation a cause or a
mechanism oh you said it's going to
happen
okay you said uh my horse is going to
win tomorrow at the race that's a
prediction yeah you haven't explained
why he's going to win okay
an explanation is a theory okay so
remember if you explain something now we
have a theory
the theory of special relativity Sr
right is not a theory but a description
okay
it's not there's no explanation in in
special relativity okay special
relativity predicts that an object
traveling at near sea will shorten in
the direction of travel gain weight and
waste your time that's what special
relativity is in a nutshell uh uh Sr you
know special relativity does not explain
the physical mechanism underlying these
events these phenomena okay they don't
explain that they just say it's going to
happen we measured it we hear the
numbers okay you told us that it's going
to shrink but you haven't told us why
what cause what physically is happening
in there that's what we need that's an
explanation that's a theory okay
and it says the
um the icing on the cake is that um
a special relativity denies that these
phenomena are real why because they say
that in a in your proper uh location
right proper length proper Mass proper
time you know that's the one the guy is
carrying with them the watch that you're
carrying that's proper time uh the ruler
you're carrying that's proper length and
the mass you know whatever the grand
kilo that's close to you that's got a
given Mass
so what is it about it's about the guy
far away who's measuring all this stuff
so it's about measurement not about what
is
okay what is is proper and proper has
not changed they say so it has not
changed who cares you could be drunk for
all I care measuring from afar and that
changes nothing existence has nothing to
do with special relativity cleans its
nose holes with it because special
relativity says from afar we're going to
measure and we're going to measure
differently than the guy who is close to
the object
okay which is called the proper length
proper Mass proper time
and so if for him the time doesn't
change
then that's the real time that's the one
mother nature uh blesses not that what
the guy measured out there you know we
don't care what he measured okay that's
what special relativity is about and
again if they say it's real which they
don't because they say in its proper
frame of reference nothing changed okay
so they do concede that so nothing
changed and uh it's a question of
measurement who cares about that if you
measured wrong or you you measured uh
something with the wrong device who
cares
measurement means that you're wrong you
just gotta correct uh the device you use
to measure that's all it means so uh
um
yeah it says a special relativity
strictly an issue of measurement and
therefore no concern whatsoever to
physics or science okay it's an issue of
measurement and we don't care about that
that's something concerns the
mathematicians you know they want to
play around with the fact that something
measured differently okay fine uh Joey
measure one thing Johnny measures
something else who cares you know who is
correct well correct is the guy who
matches Mother Nature okay if there's 10
marbles in the bag and that's a unit of
measure we have 10. and the guy can
travel at the speed of light he can go
do whatever he wants uh there's still
going to be 10 in there okay nothing's
going to change okay and so don't tell
me that the mass increase that now we
have more marbles because you traveled
at the speed of light
I'd like to have whatever he had uh I
want to strip out the speed of light too
okay so here we have uh some uh
Authority okay yeah fermula we have the
Don Lincoln he's of who
does physics you know uh physics
mathematics that's what he does he just
tried to explain tries to explain
um uh what the mathematicians do or what
they believe in what this religion is
all about okay and here it is
um and yeah he's a caricature of a
physicist and he says relativity has
been 30 tested
uh and there is no credible uh criticism
of the theory and he's so gullible you
know he just uh he just accepts all this
stuff at face value you know it's just
like he he just memorized it in in
school or something you know it's and he
just spits it out okay so uh you know
they just say look it's a fact we've
proven it uh well this is what we
believe in and we believe the
um you know the uh ruler shortened in
One Direction and gained weight and time
uh was wasted
that's that's what they come down to but
he does say one uh thing which is a
historical thing okay here it is he says
uh relativity key concept Lawrence gamma
right okay so the Lawrence gamma is the
key uh Concept in uh special relativity
and uh I went over that a couple weeks
ago uh somewhat not very important for
science or physics that's why we don't
dwell on that nonsense it's an equation
that's what it is and the question here
that I'm gonna raise is not that it has
any validity or any importance really
validity we don't care but it has no
importance in science or physics okay
it's got to do with mathematics with
them using that to say oh a length
contracted Mass increase time dilated
okay what I want to show is that it
wasn't any you know Einstein who came up
with any of that okay and here you have
a little bit of history in a chart okay
okay uh how uh this equation which you
see it there learns Factor okay that's
the gamma that they were talking about
that uh Fermi lab was talking about
um in 1887 we have Michelson and Morley
and what they did was um
they ran in a series of experiments this
was I guess the most important one where
they wrote their paper and they said
look there's no ether everybody believed
until then that there's all these
particles out there filling the vacuum
space right and at the movement of these
particles is what light is the vibration
of these particles okay and uh about a
year later all these people uh heavy
side Fitzgerald and Lawrence all these
people believed in The Ether and they
they were a little upset that at the
results and so they tried to explain to
Michelson Morley experiment and he said
look look let's not abandon The Ether we
just have to explain it okay and so
heavy side
he had worked with uh what he called
charges
electrons and he wrote a paper where he
said look in the direction of travel the
electron flattens out so that was the
length contraction and Fitzgerald heard
about that he said oh you can apply that
too late as well so maybe the photon of
light or whatever light is maybe the
wave you know flattens out in the
direction of travel and so he wrote
first to a magazine to a I think to
Science magazine or one of those
important ones and then he wrote a paper
by the time you get three years later to
Lawrence he comes in there and he comes
up with this Lawrence factor which Again
The crucial factor is that one minus V
squared over c squared velocity of the
object over velocity or light right
squared and this had already
been coming through you know there were
lots of mathematicians that had already
worked with that relation but today we
give credit to Lawrence okay and say
okay he came up with a gamma factor and
this is the one they're gonna use to
multiply and divide and to show that
time dilates and mass increases and uh
that contracts and one of the guys who
did a lot of that work was Juan Clare he
was a french guy uh and you can see how
Einstein was in all those years he was
eight years old in the days of
Michaelson Morley nine years old when
heavy side wrote his paper or or yeah
his paper really because he did write a
paper and um Fitzgerald he was 10 years
old when Fitzgerald proposes it for to
explain the ether uh Lawrence uh
ain't saying words what 13 years old and
then finally he took the credit for
discovering special relativity nobody
knows any of these other guys everybody
just knows Einstein okay he's given the
credit for all of it today and I just
want to point out that you know that is
not the case in fact here you'll look it
up in the Wikipedia okay this is a list
of all the people who worked all the
mathematicians right that worked on the
Lorenz Factor okay and uh there's a few
of them there okay so you can look this
up okay it's all those people who
contributed to the notion of uh this
Lorenz Factor until they finally zeroed
in 1892 on this gamma factor which is
what they use to
um uh explain the measurements right
that's what the how it works okay
they're still having to explain the
physical cause okay and that's why it's
not a theory all they're saying is look
if you put this Factor in there that's
what it'll do to to the equation
okay that explains the equation it
doesn't explain what happened to the
object why it increased in Mass why uh
it time dilated and why uh length
contracted okay what we want to know is
the physical mechanism that causes an
object to do all these things when it
travels close to the speed of light
that explanation that theory is not
you'll never find it in special
relativity okay there's no explanation
okay and uh what's interesting about all
that is that um Einstein even today is
credited with having gotten rid of The
Ether
they say that's what was different
that's what his contribution was uh to
uh length contraction and the Lawrence
factor and all this stuff special
relativity his stuff was getting rid of
the Ethan
not true okay here's uh Einstein 1920
and we're talking in 1908 is when
special relativity was is given birth
you could say even 1905 with the mass
um paper that uh Einstein wrote okay
that's another way of looking at it you
can also look at it from uh Juan Gores
uh work which preceded Einstein's okay
and uh this is what Einstein says 1920
several years later he says we may say
that according to the general theory of
your relativity and I remember special
relativity is a special case of general
relativity where there where gravity
where there is no gravity it's flat land
essentially you know you can't fall down
in flatland not special relativity uh
what they've done is taken away away
gravity but it's a special case of
general relativity that's why it's
called General and when the other one's
called special right we may say that
according to the general theory of
relativity space is endowed with
physical qualities so he says space is
physical that's what Einstein was saying
1920. in this sense therefore there
exists an ether
so he's saying that space is filled with
ether there is all these bunch of
particles in there some say it's moving
some say it's static they have all these
versions right but uh ether is a bunch
of particles that's all it is many
particles and just in case many
particles does not an object make
okay uh a tree a tree is an object okay
a child is an object Forest is not an
object okay Forest is many trees
children as many children
many Childs okay so according to the
general uh theory of relativity space
without an ether is Unthinkable okay so
um yeah Einstein did not get rid of The
Ether uh what he contributed was his
name that's all he did he put his name
on special relativity took the credit
for all of it
okay and what is interesting is that you
know he eventually ended up in Princeton
at the advanced studies there in
Princeton that's where he worked the
last few years of his life
and here he confesses
what happened in the last uh six years
of his life six seven years of his life
and what did he conclude he concluded he
knows nothing
that he's an ignorant individual that he
his life was wasted okay and this is
what Einstein says okay he says I'm
generally regarded as a sort of
petrified object rendered blind and deaf
by the years people were laughing at him
because he did not believe in Quantum
specifically I have become an obstinate
heretic in the eyes of my colleagues
and then he says all these 50 years of
conscious brooding have brought me no
nearer to the answer to the question
what are like quanta nowadays every Tom
Dick and Harry thinks he knows it but he
is mistaken I consider it quite possible
that physics cannot be based on the
field concept what did I say come up
with the field equation right in other
words on continuous structures in that
case nothing remains of my entire castle
in the air gravitation Theory included
and of the rest of modern physics
yeah Einstein died an ignorant man he
died this illusion he could never figure
out how this universe works at all
and so he became this he became an
atheist in his own religion here's a
pastor here's the pope of general
relativity and special relativity he
took the credit for that as well and
turns out he dies saying you know I
became an atheist in my own religion I
don't believe in it
that's how messed up all the
mathematicians that picked up on what
Einstein
the foundations he laid they picked up
on that distorted it so much and
Einstein said you guys are all crazy
and so they said well you're too old
they didn't say he was crazy Jesus he
was old and so it's interesting and you
have people like uh don Lincoln who
Worship in fact everybody out there
worships uh Einstein here we have
another uh YouTuber who tries to worship
and raise the the value of Einstein You
know to her Pope her hero okay and this
is uh awesome feathers okay and she's
got this little Einstein there and says
I'm All Shook Up
what we need is Elvis here to put some
music behind that okay
so yeah Einstein died an ignorant man he
never discovered anything he didn't he
didn't
all he did was mislead a generation
full 100 Years of it of uh
mathematicians
down the wrong path that's how Einstein
contributed to so-called science to
physic in other words nothing uh you
could say he contributed negative uh
knowledge negative information negative
explanations
because all the explanations we have
today from mathematical physics for all
invisible intangible objects out there
that mediate you know how these
phenomenal work is all irrational not
one not one okay out of mathematical
physics passes the rationality test
okay so let's move on to the subject
matter of today let's see if we can find
out what it is okay give me a second
here
clean some of this up put a lot of stuff
okay so here we go
um
today we're going to be talking about
gravity
what is gravity
and I always do a an experiment you saw
it here for the first time ever okay
nobody else on planet Earth has ever
done this experiment very expensive okay
we take a pencil okay watch carefully
because this is this is astounding and
you let go of it
it falls to the floor to the table in
this case and just in case I'll do it
repeatable because it's got to be
repeatable in mathematics for it to be
scientific so we let go of it here it
goes there you go see you let go of it
falls to the floor never has it fall
into the ceiling whenever I do it okay
and so the question is what brings it
down
why does it come down what causes it
what's the mechanism
okay what comes in contact with the
pencil what physical object called I
mean you know uh I'm holding it so so
when I hold it with my fingers yeah it
stays there but as soon as I let go of
it you know it comes down yeah no way
you can stop it and so the question is
why does it go up I mean I wanted to go
up sometime and it doesn't never been
able to do that magic trick okay
okay so what's the deal well
uh here's a couple people
several really I've got three cases here
where people have
shown that
when you drop it it falls to the ground
but then you have you know this inertia
this resistance that we talked about a
minute ago okay
um like the air you know if it's if you
take a feather you let go and you know
it doesn't fall like a stone does it
kind of floats there why because it's
got this resistance there's inertia I
guess right and a little bit of inertia
a little bit of resistance okay and uh
and so the feather doesn't fall at the
same rate at the same acceleration as a
stone and here you have uh one file his
name is Brian green and he went to a
special place to do this experiment they
dropped a feather and a ball
and they both fell at the same time why
because that uh that uh chamber they
removed all the air okay and so you can
see there's no resistance and it's uh
uncanny it's a really unbelievable that
you know a feather would fall at the
same rate as anything else instead of
floating and all they did was remove you
know the um
uh the air and here's another example of
that okay a fellow did the same thing he
had uh two boxes in one he removed the
air and other ones he left it and you
can see the one with air with the uh
feather does it kind of drifts because
it's got all this resistance with the
air and the other one where there's no
air just Falls at the same rate as the
little metal piece there okay
and just in case uh for those of you who
are not flat earthers we did it on the
moon as well and Astronaut dropped a
feather and a hammer and you can see
that they fall at the same time okay so
he did it as careful as he could okay
and there it is no no air on the moon
okay so he proved proved that there's no
air on the moon right and without that
resistance the Feather Falls at the same
rate as the hammer okay so we call that
phenomena gravity they both fall down
you can see that even on the moon for
those of you who are not a flat earthers
the uh hammer and the feather did not go
out into space
they both fell to the center of the Moon
in that direction right okay because the
Moon is round and again not for flat
earthers flat Earth I think the Moon is
flat I guess right okay so what is this
gravity thingy that pulls it down here's
a definition okay one's from
dictionary.com the other one from
Wikipedia and one says Gravity the force
of attraction by which terrestrial
bodies tend to fall toward the center of
the earth okay that's the notion what is
it it's a force of attraction
essentially right and Wikipedia says a
fundamental interaction which causes
mutual attraction between all things
with math or energy okay so you have a
mutual attraction and you have the force
of attraction uh or fundamental
interaction right the question is you
have an attraction
so uh the remedy is not repulsive okay
so whenever you let go of it falls to
the ground unless there is some
resistance and then we have to go into
inertia but if there is no resistance
it'll just or the resistance is
irrelevant like in the case of a stone
and the thing will fall at the rate that
it should be falling which is 9.8 meters
per second Square that's the
acceleration of gravity here on Earth
and that's how fast or how you know the
acceleration of gravity here that's how
you can expect the thing to fall to the
ground at that rate okay so uh gravity
is some kind of force
that's a concept so far we haven't said
what gravity is all we're saying is look
uh we're going to call that phenomena
gravity okay what does gravity gravity
means that uh something falls to the
floor
essentially there's a attraction there's
um uh what is it
um uh you could say it's attracted by
the Earth somehow okay magically
whatever but it's attractive and here's
NASA okay this is their version it says
gravity is a force okay and again go to
the same thing as the other two and then
it says why do you land on the ground
when you uh jump up instead of floating
off into space yeah why and it says why
do things fall down when you throw them
up or drop them okay why
yeah I want to know why the answer is
gravity
gravity is just a name you could have
said the answer is intelligence
the answer is love
I mean love is attractive usually right
so uh okay so it's love and what do you
mean by that I mean did love cause uh I
mean we're talking physics here right
did love bring it down
you know what's the physical mechanism
and of course no one even remotely has
any idea okay uh all these
mathematicians they never discovered
that here we are 2 000 plus years later
since the Greeks dealt with some of
these issues nobody has figured it out
out there in mathematical physics and we
have but not them okay
okay so here we have uh foul jumping on
the moon on the earth okay and you can
see he tries to jump but he doesn't go
out into space he falls back to Earth
okay and um
so what they've concocted is they said
well you know the ether maybe or who
knows what and we have all these
particles right and they think it's it's
a question of particles okay and so they
try to explain it with particles but see
the problem is with particles coming out
of objects such as atoms right they can
only go one way
so assuming you know there are particles
coming out of your body out of every
atom in your body right and photons for
example right and then you have all
these particles we'll assume that they
exist right and all these particles are
coming from every direction they're
coming even from the atoms on the Earth
so why would you still why would you
fall towards the center of the earth why
not I mean if you if you're in the
middle of all these particles it's
coming from every direction you
shouldn't move anywhere okay if you jump
you should stay up in the air
why do you come down you know you can't
explain with particles
and uh someone who simulated these
things with particles was Newton but he
gave up you know he wrote a couple
things that we have from him today one
is a letter to uh Richard Bentley and he
says that gravity should be essential to
matter so that one body may act upon
another at a distance through a vacuum
without the mediation of anything else
by and through which their action and
force may be conveyed from one to
another is to me so great an absurdity
that I believe no man who has competent
faculty of thinking can ever fall into
it okay and so he says gravity must be
caused by an agent
yeah and then in his book he says I do
not feign hypothesis
okay he had no idea but he simulated
everything with particles because he had
no other idea what to simulate that with
okay but he was under the idea that yeah
gravity must be caused by an agent but
it turns out that he can't see or touch
whatever this agent is things simply
fall to the floor and I can't see your
touch what's pushing or pulling them
downwards okay so he finally gave up he
says you know I feign no hypothesis
it's but he did everything with
particles he was a particle man
corpuscles okay okay
so today uh the people in quantum
mechanics
they haven't given up on particles
because their religion is a quantum uh
based on on the quantum on the on the
particle okay particle that ain't a
particle by the way it's a an amount
quantity it's a number but they treat it
as a ball okay whenever they want to
give their physical interpretation okay
and so here you have a couple uh
instances okay here's a Quantum
attraction
um they call it transfer of negative
momentum and here's just an example a
quark shooting a glue on outwards and
somehow drawing another Quark inwards
you know and and here you have another
fellow and his name is John Baez Juanito
Baez I call him says if I throw a ball
at you the recoil pushes me back he says
the answer and he's trying to explain he
says the answer lies in the Heisenberg's
uncertainty principle the photon can be
created by one particle and absorbed by
the other if the momentum transferred by
the wave points in the direction from
the receiving particle to the emitting
one the effect is that of an attractive
Force here it goes again just in case
if I throw a ball at you the recoil
pushes me back when you catch the ball
you are pushed away from me how can this
attract
us to each other yeah good question the
answer lies in the Heisenberg
uncertainty principle the photon can be
created by one particle and absorbed by
the other
okay so that's what he's saying it's
absorbed if the momentum is the moment
transferred by the wave points in the
direction from the receiving particle to
the emitting one the effect is an
attractive Force
okay so you can see uh how they're doing
all this magic they can do it
mathematically they say yeah we just
change the sign or whatever and uh yeah
that's great that's got nothing to do
with physics tell me
show me in a lab how you can do that
okay you like experiments there that's
that's where you have to do experiments
just show me an experiment where uh you
show gravity right uh with uh negative
momentum okay just uh simulate throw a
tennis ball at something and Attract it
okay
and here's another fella his name is
Victor Stanger and give me a second here
to so we get to this beginning
uh the vacuum is capable of producing
interactions between particles at
effective space like separation this
occurs when Quantum fluctuations in the
vacuum cause a particle to zigzag let me
explain now that the idea of motion
backward in time makes a grievous
assault on Common Sense yeah however to
a particle physicist raised on a diet of
Feynman diagrams motion backward in time
is not all that disturbing all
fundamental particle interactions work
backward as well as forward
and so these people believe that they
can get away with saying look
um we just changed time we put a
negative sign in front of the Little T
and we've got it made okay so these
folks are really saying that you know
they can produce attraction by throwing
something outwards uh one way
okay they have no problem believing this
and the question is how do they justify
it uh rationally and they can't they
just say you know again like this will
says you can't even imagine that how do
you throw the ball in a tract and so
they had to create negative momentum
transfer and that answered I guess
Newton's uh concern you know how how do
you produce attraction with particles
and these people said we can do it we
just caught negative momentum transfer
we transfer attraction
okay so uh what is that uh particle
called It's called The graviton and what
is a graviton well here you have a
an idea uh says the graviton is the
hypothetical Quantum of gravity and
elementary particle that mediates the
force of gravitational interaction this
is all out of the Wikipedia there is no
complete Quantum field theory of
gravitons due to the out to an
outstanding mathematical problem with
renormalization in general relativity
okay in string theory okay so they moved
from Quantum to string theory now which
is a variation on Quantum that's all it
is one of the vibrational states of the
string gives rise to the graviton okay
so they're just saying that it's a
little
a string that's vibrating uh it's more
like a
you know like this
so
more like something like this and they
move it around in different direction
they say well that's a particle okay
great and so it says uh one vibrational
states of the string gives the rise of
graviton a quantum mechanical particle
that carries carries gravitational force
carries it on the back okay they always
talk about carrying Force carrying
interactions how you do that I don't
know and we don't carry Concepts in
science
the string theory is a theory of quantum
gravity
okay you got that it's a theory of
quantum gravity in three Theory the
graviton is a massless state of a
fundamental string if a massless spin
two particle is discovered it must be
the graviton
so uh here you have a picture of that
okay
this is what a graviton looks like okay
so if you see something like that around
your house floating around hey call the
people at CERN slack
fermilab you know any of those
um Brookhaven National Laboratories any
others tell them that you've seen in
graviton okay it looks something like
that so now you know what it looks like
no excuses okay
okay so if you see something floating
like that it's not a
unidentified flight object it's a
graviton okay
okay so here we have one file his name
is Matt Dowd he's got uh again he's uh
sponsored by uh PBS I call it BS more
than PBS okay and this is what he says
he says dozens of these cosmic strings
in a network Across the Universe okay so
all these uh strings somehow open up
they break and then they weld together
or sew together he doesn't explain the
process he doesn't explain how that
happens they just uh they just do it
they just describe and illustrate that
the string this closed loop string this
closed loop rubber band or string or
whatever it breaks forms uh
uh you know welds or whatever with other
strings and then they form these Loops
again then they break again and they do
all this stuff and nobody tells us how
that happens okay
and what the math does you know he goes
in there and uh he says the following he
says
a pair of kinks in the string are
whipped back and forth by the
oscillating string okay we see it there
okay and the incredible mass in these
Kinks they have incredible Mass okay no
I don't know how they justify that they
just say it does
causes them to radiate gravitational
waves
and so they slowly Decay away
gravitational waves I guess he's talking
about space time right these waves are
going to travel through space-time
because these massive strings they
vibrate and all these waves come out of
there fine no problem how does that wave
that comes towards me attract me that's
what I want them to tell me because a
wave like a particle is a one-way
mechanism it goes outwards and does not
come in okay so we have a problem
because these people do not explain the
mechanism or they say look it does so
okay so the wave comes out of the string
you know the closed loop string vibrates
creates waves in space-time I guess goes
outwards no problem and here I'm on the
receiving end so we have a waves coming
towards me like you know in the ocean
when the waves come towards you
well the wave is not pulling you in it's
pushing you out you know uh you could
say that you know later on it pulls you
inwards okay but that's not what these
people are saying these people are not
saying besides it's not going to pull
you all you know even if you're pulled
by by the way if you're not going to be
dragged all the way to the black hole
okay so what is the pull mechanism
because uh again uh gravity is an
attractive Force explain attraction with
this wave or your particles either way
okay and that's where they can't they
don't have that okay but it says uh that
uh the string disappears disappears into
weather because part of space time I
mean here you have the string right this
thing right it's vibrating it sends
waves Out and because it loses all this
energy in the waving motion this
disappears
where does it go I mean does it melt
away does it become part of space-time
was it a thing to begin with I mean is
it a wave is it a what is this a
one-dimensional string I mean I don't
know anything that's one dimensional I
mean
what does one dimensional look like
and they say it only has length
foreign
so uh we'll draw it for me
draw your one one-dimensional length
okay
and unfortunately someone here his name
is Brian Cox he tells us where these
gravitons go why they disappear why we
can't see them okay this is important
here so pay attention and he says the
following says that it goes to Hidden
dementia okay you have Dimension is one
dementia I guess in many right the
reason gravitons disappear is that they
vanish into a place beyond our reality
into some sort of extra Dimension okay
great how many drinks did you have there
can be extra hidden unseen Dimensions
okay great it sounds ridiculous
absolutely that's why I asked how many
drinks you had bartender I want whatever
he had and it is impossible to picture
but theoretically it's possible I mean
these people are so gullible they
believe anything that you know their
teachers tell them and they just
memorize it for the test and then spread
it out among Humanity right and it's
also possible that gravitons the
particles of gravity can spend most of
their time in those extra dimensions
so uh yeah if you're looking for a
graviton uh go to the other dimension
you'll find it there
okay that's what they're saying they're
hiding in the extra dimension
okay and uh so uh that's the quantum
string version right here you have
iony's version we covered that the other
day it's very simple so we don't need to
spend more time on this the Earth
doesn't fly out of the solar system
because there's this canvas known as
warp time okay we have the seconds and
the minutes which are warped or the
years maybe right and they're warped and
they come up against the skin of our
planet and prevent the spline our planet
from flying out of the solar system
that's what keeps our ball rolling
around the Sun
okay and so what can I say
um you know these are the versions that
you get these are the explanations the
mechanisms that they offer you in
mathematical physics
and so if you believe any of them well I
don't know I think you need to see a
doctor
called the shrink
okay how do we explain it
well obviously we explain it very simple
because it is very simple all we needed
to do here okay when we had the pencil
right all we needed to do here is figure
out what invisible thing
object entity whatever you want to call
it body is here or here
something that comes in contact with a
pencil
if it comes in contact with a pencil we
can explain why it falls because there
is no action at a distance there is
something in contact with a pencil
physical contact with a pencil other
than the air by right there's something
invisible intangible that's coming in
contact with a pencil
okay if you said there ain't
you say that there is nothing that's in
contact with a pencil because we cannot
see it or touch it
you are explaining this phenomenon with
black magic you're saying this happens
by Magic with nothing touching it
nothing can come in contact with it when
you jump and you fall back to Earth why
do you fall back to Earth well nothing
is in contact with me yes something had
better be in contact with you otherwise
you are explaining your phenomenon the
fact that you jump and you're pulled
right back you're explaining that with
black magic
okay
so before we explain our version let's
give a um an introduction to it you have
to know what we're trying to figure out
here okay and this is a very important
uh thing that uh a professor his name is
Richard Mueller he works or worked at
least at Berkeley okay and this is what
he had to say about what it is that you
have to explain about gravity okay
listen carefully okay this is not mine
this is someone at Berkeley Professor
right that's what he says okay here he
goes listen carefully
what's the force of gravity on me
um
it's the pull of the Earth on my body
so for example if you have the Earth
when it's a big Mass here and you have
you
with your little Mass here
at every atom on the Earth
is pulling every atom of you
you're also pulling on it
I've never had a lot of atoms here
you're pulling on you're pulling on all
of them amazing thing about gravity is
it goes right through things
okay
every atom of you every single atom in
your body of you is pulling on every
atom of Earth every atom of Earth is
pulling on every atom of you
okay if you say there's nothing there
because you cannot see or touch it
you're doing black magic
the only way you can pull
on every atom on Earth and for every
atom on Earth to pull on you is because
there's an invisible intangible thing
elongated thing that is connected
from every atom in your body to every
atom on Earth there is no other
explanation for that and the only reason
the mathematicians have not ever come up
with that is because they could not see
or touch it
but an object is not that which you can
see your touch an object is that which
has shape
an elongated object has shape
Rhythm 3D object right as shape
it doesn't necessarily mean you can see
or touch it okay that's the bottom line
that's that's what prevented this from
or why it took more than two thousand
years to figure this out because they
could not see or touch it and they said
we're going to resolve this through
mathematics no you can't because and you
can't resolve it through an experiment
because if you cannot see or touch it
you cannot go to the lab and say I'm
going to see or touch
whatever is mediating gravity you can't
because you can't see or touch it is
that clear and this is what these people
never figured out because they're trying
to do math they're just doing saying
well this is the force of attraction
yeah that doesn't tell me what caused it
the mechanism okay that's the issue okay
so we got that straight uh that's what
we have to explain
and here we have it
this is the difference between
mathematical physics everything's been
that's been done until today they're
talking about discrete particles that's
why they cannot explain anything that's
why they talk about action at a distance
another proposal we have here is we say
that all atoms are interconnected now
you can explain why every atom on Earth
pulls on every atom of you and you pull
on it because every atom in your body is
connected to every physically connected
to every atom on Earth
it's connected via an uh intangible uh
invisible entity uh we call it the Rope
because that's the shape it has and
that's the only reason for that but it's
an elongated very elongated very skinny
very thin object that we cannot see or
touch we pass our hands right through it
okay and that's why uh every atom of you
pulls on every atom of Earth every atom
on Earth pulls on every atom of you
which is what we have to explain and
here we explain we're saying every atom
in your body is connected to every atom
on Earth we're done that's how simple it
was no Mass no energy no field no Force
none of those mathematical words just
physics we're saying there's a your atom
is attached to the atoms on Earth every
atom in your body is attached to every
atom of me
okay and so on all atoms in the universe
are physically interconnected
no action at a distance no black magic
if once you have the connection it's
easy to understand it's kids stuff okay
and I always give the example you know
yeah
a guy brings his ten-year-old son and
they see a farmer pulling on a donkey
from a rope right tied around the
donkey's neck so as he pulls the donkey
comes towards him
so the man asked his son now how did he
get the donkey from point A to point B
closer to the man to the farmer and the
guy said the kid says you know he pulled
down the road you know it's so simple
it's just not even you know a no-brainer
you just it's what you saw saw him
pulling on the room pulling on the
Donkey
now make the Rope disappear and now the
farmer goes like that and the donkey
comes towards him
and now he the father asked his son how
did the donkey go from point A to point
B and the kid says I have no clue I
don't know how that happened Magic
and the only issue is that he can't see
the Rope
because if he could see the Rope it was
a kid stuff but if you can't see the
Rope oh it's black magic it's we'll
never answer the question that's all it
is that's the where we're at today okay
okay so um here we have
uh our explanation for Gravity okay here
it is uh we call them effective ropes
you have five atoms in a cube tied to
one atom number six in the cylinder okay
that's we call it one effective rope
because essentially it's uh a pull or a
tug between one and six two three four
and five don't exist for all practical
purposes because they're on the same
axis so they're all pulling on the same
uh line so to speak but what happens
when they go out of alignment for
example when the distance between the
cylinder and the cube change cylinder
comes closer well now you can see that
the atoms are the ropes that connect or
these effective we call them effective
rope now each rope is pulling
independently and not on the same axis
and so it's like suddenly you have fiber
Oaks okay instead of one okay and that's
why gravity increases as two objects
come closer to each other and then on
the upper right you'll see two objects
far away they have all the ropes more or
less on the same axis and lots of them
are exactly on the same axis they
superimpose and again because there's no
C or touch between ropes okay they don't
touch each other they super impose
perfectly well okay and that's what
people have trouble understanding or
accepting okay but that's an assumption
you have to make
and then what happens as the objects
come closer together well the ropes fan
out and you can see how gravity is
becoming stronger and stronger as the
distance between the two objects
decreases okay so what is uh Newton's
equation weight equals uh gravitational
constant G mass mass divided by a
distance squared well what you're
talking about is the number of effective
ropes that's what the mass mass divided
by distance Square Factor represents it
in fact represents the number of
effective ropes okay that's our
explanation okay
and so here we have uh a comparison okay
of the three proposals okay here's the
quantum slash
um
String Theory proportion proposal okay
you have all these particles coming from
the Earth to the Sun or the Sun to the
Earth and somehow that prevents the
Earth from flying out of the solar
system how do you produce that by
throwing particles one way
okay so whether the Earth throws
particle at the Sun or the Sun at the
Earth it doesn't explain the mechanism
it doesn't explain gravity it doesn't
explain why the Earth doesn't go flying
out of the solar system okay uh so it
doesn't it's an irrational mechanism to
produce to introduce particles here's
the relativity version which is another
one okay here you have the earth going
around space time space time the sun is
in the center blowing or pushing I guess
the canvas downwards and so because it
pushes it downwards it creates this
depression in time okay so we have warp
time that's what the green stuff
represents and now that you have that
green what time the Earth that cannot uh
fall uh or fall out of the solar system
you could say or fly out why because its
surface is rolling or sliding around
that warp time
what sense does that make none at all
whatsoever so don't tell me you proved
it tell me uh tell me what the mechanism
is tell me how you you're going to warp
time what are you warping the seconds
the minutes
and here's our version okay and you can
see it here uh very easy to understand
uh the sun simply Twirls the Earth
around itself okay and why because all
atoms on Earth are connected to all
every single atom and the sun the sun
simply goes around and Twirls the Earth
around itself
okay and that's easy to understand now
you know why the earth goes around the
Sun there's no friction between the
Earth and space because space is
absolutely nothing meaning it's that
which has no shape
so uh there is no friction between Earth
and space space cannot uh Earth cannot
rub you know Gaia cannot run rub its her
shoulder uh or her elbow against space
because space is absolutely nothing
meaning that which has no shape there is
no ether in there uh
uh it's not filled with energy or Fields
or any of that nonsense no all we have
is between objects between atoms you
have these elongated entities we'll call
them ropes okay and that's why you know
celestial objects don't fly out for
example out of the solar system they're
swimming around and then
um is there something out there in space
all we have is the crisscrossing or
ropes from other
uh atoms in the universe going right
through the Earth and out to other atoms
on the other side of the universe that
we have across the entire universe
people say how many ropes are there uh
we don't care there's lots of them
there's lots of atoms in the universe
there's lots of ropes
very simple stuff no biggie okay
quantity is not an issue okay so those
people who raise quantity issues are
simply uh chasing their tail around
okay let's get down to the questions
we're not going to do our Science Guy
today we finished the other day
essentially we've said everything we had
to say I guess about predictions okay so
there's nothing more to add
uh essentially he has a different
version of the scientific method that's
the one they shoved up there's nose
holes you know and uh high school or
college or whatever and that's what he
believes that's what he's been educated
on brainwashed on uh hypnotized on and
all he does is repeat it he doesn't try
to make sense of any of that okay
okay so here we have it
um
uh far says I used to I used math to
create Angels does this mean angels
exist he was answering another fellow
there and it's a good question you know
I mean the fact that you can uh
mathematically say look I I created
space time in my math I've got all these
coordinates does that mean there's a
physical object called space time out
there okay the fact that you can do it
mathematically okay and here here's an
example okay here we have the earth
going around the Sun okay and okay we've
seen that we all recognize that no
biggie but uh what if I told you look
that angels exist so here you have the
angel taking the Earth around the Sun
how's that for an explanation could that
be true okay
and I'm saying that just because you can
conceptualize Angels you cannot come up
with a theory and say well Angels push
the Earth around the Sun and likewise it
makes no sense to say that you know that
um general relativity space time is the
one that's going to uh
prevent the Earth from flying out of the
solar system is space-time a physical
object is there such an entity such a
space-time and the answer hopefully is
no okay
okay so uh let's get these fellas out of
here
another fellow says
there are a hundred plus theories of
ether okay hey yeah your robot theory is
just another ether Theory well first of
all rope is not a theory it's a
hypothesis it's an assumption you make
an assumption which is not a theory okay
you may get assumption say let us assume
that every atom in the universe is
connected to all others
by uh by means of uh a rope or some
elongated object could be a line or
whatever I don't know you can propose
whatever you want it's an assumption not
a theory okay so far we haven't
explained any you know we did was
proposing assumption the guy says the
Rope Theory so he's already started on
the wrong shoe okay but what's the issue
uh he says it's uh there's a bunch of
ether theories out there again uh The
Ether is an assumption okay it's not a
theory in itself and you look up the
word ether and I challenge anyone out
there to do so because nobody can tell
me what the ether is everybody tells me
I'm wrong that I don't know what the
ether is fine no problem I'll accept
that tell me what the ether is is The
Ether a physical object draw it
illustrate it point to it somewhere on
the internet and if it's a concept
Define it tell me what you think the
word ether is what what it represents
what is The Ether to you don't tell me
I'm wrong tell me what's right
okay and here you have it if you look up
uh the word ether
uh in the images right I Google that and
that's what you get okay uh so
apparently nobody has any idea what the
ether is out there especially all those
people who propose The Ether fact uh one
fellow they're uh Jeffy uh where you say
uh see up at the top what is ether it's
a YouTube video and he goes in there and
he uh he believes in The Ether okay
tells you why
and but he says what is The Ether and
what is ether and he never tells you
what the ether is
okay he doesn't tell you what it is he
says it's a substance that fills space
you haven't told me anything
that's not what the ether is point to it
if it's a what if it's a thing
you know point to it draw it illustrate
it and again they can't illustrate The
Ether they just tell you that you don't
know what the ether is
I know but you don't okay I don't I'm
ignorant I don't know what ether is tell
me what it is is it a thing Illustrated
if it's a concept Define it once again
okay
okay so uh since they don't I do I do
illustrate The Ether and you can't
illustrate it because it's a bunch of
particles that's why you can't
illustrate The Ether
okay now you're saying you just
Illustrated Bill no because a bunch of
particles does not an object make shape
is what an object what characterizes an
object and right now it doesn't have
shape I put a frame around it because I
didn't want to have an infinite object
right meaning uh infinity of particles
so I put the frame around that just to
show you what uh all these people have
thought about The Ether for centuries
okay and what they say is that the ether
is in other words light is the vibration
of The Ether and this is what they
illustrate okay this is what they have
in mind they're saying look all these
particles are vibrating and that's what
light is it's the vibration of these
gazillions of particles
okay so that's what the ether is so if
you don't believe that if you don't like
this you don't say you don't agree with
this definition this notion then tell us
what the ether is if it's an is if it's
a what then illustrate it okay you can't
just say you don't know what it is now I
know I know don't know what it is I want
you to tell us what it is okay it's the
ball is in your chord if you're gonna
vouch for The Ether okay so let's get it
right
okay so is my theory an ether Theory
well
this is what I propose now does that
look like a bunch of particles you just
saw
okay so I guess not this is a little
different the black stuff is space and I
put a ring around it but uh actually
you know space is not finite or Infinite
Space is a concept it's a synonym of
nothing what is nothing that which has
no shape what is something that which
has shape okay so the thread that you
see there I made it kind of fat kind of
thick okay but you can think of it as
very thin extremely thin and that's all
there is in the universe and what does
this thread do well this thread converts
into everything that we see you have the
single closed loop thread uh it's twined
around more twined and eventually it
ends up being atoms and the
interconnections that uh well that
connect every atom in the universe okay
interconnected atoms okay that's the
Assumption that's what we're saying
exists out there that's what
um that's all that we have in our
universe it's a very simple Universe
it's just atoms connected to each other
that's all there is and if we were to un
on not untie uh every atom every uh rope
that connects any two atoms we would end
up with a single closed loop thread in
the universe okay so that's that's the
proposal and from there we can explain
gravity and we can explain light we can
explain all the main phenomena the basic
phenomena of physics okay no magic it's
just that we can't see or touch the
mediators what are the mediators the
mediators are the ropes and eventually
if you untangle all that mess that we've
got out there from atoms to the ropes
that interconnect them you end up with a
single closed loop thread
hey that's that's the way it works very
simple Universe none of this math
nonsense will we ever figure out we'll
never figure it out yeah we figured it
out already okay we have an explanation
you don't like our explanation come with
a better mousetrat that's the way it
works okay so you got a better
explanation uh better be rational that's
how we ask
okay follow says your question about
physical mechanism are meaningless
because the empirical reality around us
just is
so he says just I just believe it I just
accept it uh I don't need to know the
mechanisms yeah because he's not a
physicist he physicist wants to know
mechanism
we want to know why this thing falls to
the follower okay why does it fall down
we went and he says it just is but yeah
you haven't explained it with that so he
just accepted it he could just you could
just say angels and he'll accept it as
well and say God did it and it's all the
same to him okay we don't question the
mundane reality around for some hidden
mechanisms because we just accept it
and then these people why are these
people coming into physics these people
should be in church praying for their
salvation for you know reincarnation or
whatever that's how you should feel
about relativity it just it it just is a
truth about our world a true that's true
okay it's just uh no mechanism or
irrational mechanism but it's just the
truth okay truth means he accepted it
they shoved it down his throne he
swallowed it okay uh Kool-Aid you know
physics is about measurement
so we measure and we just accept it and
that's it
even Einstein can't believe what this
guy said yeah I should try to get to the
bottom of it he never did he never
figured it out died an ignorant man okay
and another person says a shadow seems
like it exists and does
but not as a thing well then it can't
exist because exists requires it to be a
thing an object a
entity whatever synonym you want to put
in there okay
with properties of its own rather it is
an absence of a thing like light yeah if
it's an absence of a thing if it's light
uh meaning vibration we're talking about
the vibration of light of the Rope the
Rope is a thing but the vibration is not
a thing it's what it the Rope does okay
so we have to distinguish when we use
the word Light Between the object and
what it does okay the noun and the verb
okay and so yeah you need a thing and um
and what the problem is it's got to be a
standalone thing uh Shadow is not a
thing you say well it's got shape not
for the purposes of physics shape means
Standalone okay if if it doesn't stand
alone if it needs help like the Halo on
the head of an Angel
you know without the Angel that's just a
plate or a ring
it becomes the word halo only if you put
the angel the holy person there okay
a Halo is not a thing okay Halo is a
concept okay because it's a relation
without the angel all you have is a
plate now you have an object or a ring
right those two are objects with the
angel it becomes a ring uh a Halo now
it's not an object Halo is a concept and
it takes uh 10 years for mathematicians
to understand what I just said
okay folks and then uh we'll stop here
and we'll see you next week same time